hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the conclusion to part three of
his prom at ten future metaphysics
Immanuel Kant is going to bring up an
important distinction and also apply it
between bounds and limits of reason and
by extension bounds and limits as such
so not every use of Reason will actually
have both of these and it's important to
clarify this at this point and we're
going to see that K will interestingly
use space IAL
metaphors in order to try to bring this
across which we'll look at after we uh
examine the distinction itself so what
is the distinction we have bounds
grenzen which are often translated as
limit Gren is uh limit but in this case
bounds or boundaries right and then we
have limits proper uh shrank
you could think of those as not having
the
spatiality that we're looking at here so
bounds or boundaries grenzen as he says
presuppose a space a real outside and in
closing what it is that they are bound
in and so he says uh outside a definite
place then he says limits shanken do not
require this they are actually mere
negations which affect a
quantity so far as it is not
absolutely complete and this absolutely
complete the complete word there you
know uh this is this is the one that
we've seen coming up over and over again
in the previous parts of the uh
proma um this is a key
idea running throughout the work
so how is this going to play out well
some uses of reason some modes of
cognition some Sciences even are not
going to have both of these and so he
says as long as the cognition of reason
the cognition that is being carried out
by reason is H
G artig again something that we've seen
talked about previously where did that
come up well a little bit earlier in
part three when we were looking at the
cosmological ideas and here just a
little bit of a digression and reminder
there were
mathematical antinomies right and then
there were dynamical antinomies and the
mathematical had to do with things that
were like Arctic that we're homogeneous
that's why they could be about you know
limitation of time and space right but
the dynamical ones weren't about things
that were actually like AR in this way
so K is going to go on and talk about
the two previous Sciences the uses of
reason that uh have been clarified in
part one and part two of the proma
asking the questions how is mathematics
pure mathematics actually possible we
know that it's possible because it's
actual right same thing with pure
natural science or the Natural Sciences
unified as science so both of these he's
going to say um in mathematics and
natural science human reason admits of
limits right negations of this sort but
not of bounds not of GZA that's
something indeed lies outside of it
which it can never arrive at but not
that it will at any point find
completion in its internal progress so
mathematics as he says is sort of like
infinitely extendable within the domain
of mathematics so it can't infinitely
extend itself into everything else but
you can have new insights new
discoveries they can come up they're
potentially infinite right we could do
mathematics forever and still be
discovering new things and why because
as he says it uh regards
appearances only we saw in part one that
it has to do with the intuitions the
pure intuitions of space and time right
and what we can derive within them and
so he says what cannot be an object of
sensuous intuition and then notice what
he's going to say here such as the
concepts of metaphysics but there's
another term that gets brought in and
then doesn't get really talked about
much here and of morals interesting
isn't that so uh these lie entirely
outside of its sphere so we have a clear
demarcation between mathematics as a IPL
which we understand quite well and
metaphysics what about the Natural
Sciences the Natural Sciences seem a
little bit closer to metaphysics don't
they we could say mathematics you know
that's all ideal that's you know stuff
that we don't actually have to be uh
seeing in in nature but you know natural
science is about natural things and
we're kind of led to thinking well
what's at the absolute basis of those
that's actually metaphysics the way that
Kant conceives of natural science or the
Natural Sciences which would by the way
include what we often call the social
sciences like
psychology um in so far as they're you
know following laws that can be
observable he says that the same is the
case with the discovery of any new
properties of nature we can make
progress into understanding physical
things right we can use a microscope and
be like holy crap look at what's what's
being revealed to us salt actually has a
crystallin structure isn't that
interesting right but that's still
within the realm of the phenomenal what
it is that we can experience and observe
so um new properties of nature new
forces and laws things that we use to
explain how things turn out the same way
over and over and over again gravity is
one that can't or you know mutual
attraction of material bodies uh K has
brought this up over and over again in
here um we can have these by continued
experience and rational unification that
is something that we attempt to do in
The Sciences we try to say how are these
things all connected with each other can
we make sense of them but the Natural
Sciences as he says can never reveal to
us um the internal constitution of
things we can never get to the things in
themselves we can never get to the very
bottom level and say aha within the
realm of experience we have discovered
the
metaphysical so what about
metaphysics he says that metaphysics
leads us towards bounds in the
dialectical attempts of pure reason and
the transcendental ideas as they do not
admit of evasion and yet are never
capable of realization serve to point
out to us actually not only the bounds
of pure reason right but the ways to
determine those bounds now do the
transcendental ideas do that all by
themselves do we say aha here you go
here's a flash card with the various
cosmological ideas on them here's
another one with the theological idea
here's another one with the
psychological idea no we have to do the
thinking about that that Kant has
actually done in section three part
three of this work the proliga and also
in the critique of pure reason right so
metaphysics is doing something different
than mathematics and natural science
metaphysics does in fact have bounds
whereas these other two don't have
bounds they merely have limits
metaphysics would presumably have both
of those to it and having bounds is
going to be incredibly important as
something determinative right and so he
says that you know metaphysics in its
fundamental features perhaps more than
any other science is placed in Us by
Nature itself it cannot be considered
the production of an AR arbitrary choice
or casual enlargement in the progress of
experience from which it is quite
disperate right so what can actually
find us these limits and these bounds
reason reason working upon itself and
producing for the first time going all
the way back to what Kant was talking
about in the earlier parts of this work
a genuine metaphysics an actual
metaphysics a critical metaphysics and
so here we're going to have to look at
two spatial metaphors that he brings up
one of these is happening at the very
beginning when he talks about bounds and
limits he says that our reason sees in
its surroundings omik literally just
around
it
what a space for the
cognition of things in
themselves so reason can't actually
attain to the things in themselves it
has to observe certain boundaries or
bounds certain G
right but reason is the one who gives
itself those who
recognizes those
and postulates we could say or
recognizes a
space outside of itself or around itself
enclosing it that includes things in
itself and we should mention too so I I
brought up morals can't when he talks
about things in themselves one of the
things in themselves that we can
actually make some progress in not fully
determining not fully
cognizing but at least grasping is
ourselves as
Freedom that's a bit of a side note
let's go on to the second metaphor which
is a little bit more
concrete so he says that uh since the
transcendental ideas have urged us to
approach them and thus have led us as it
were to the spot or the place where what
the occupied
space space that we can can roam around
in the space of he says
experience touches the void now
notice that he doesn't say touches the
void in the sense that the void is
something there this is actually an
adjective so Zur that's up to
right right um touching uh attaining to
M
Dame right with lit literally with what
happens to be empty or void right so
he's not trying to determine what the
void is you can't do that because it's a
void right and that is going to
be at the limit or at rather at the
boundary the GZA of uh this thing that
is being imposed on pure reason he says
we can determine the bounds of pure
reason right um in all bounds there's
something positive a surface is the
boundary of corporeal space therefore is
itself a space a line is a space which
the boundary which is the boundary of
the surface a point the boundary of the
line yet always a place in space whereas
limits contain mere negations and so
it's not just limits being revealed by
these spatial metaphors or through uh
reason engaging with the transcendental
ideas in a critical way we're also
getting to figure out what the bounds or
boundaries of pure reason actually are
in relation as K is going to say to the
Numa to the things in themselves which
we cannot determine but we cannot Escape
either